I mean, because, you know, you read a bunch of people, Foucault, Nietzsche, I mean, all
of these thinkers have connections, but like, the lineage seems so clear to me, like, I
find it almost impossible to delineate the thread or the type of thinking between some
of these people, it feels like they just kind of fall into each other in productive ways,
not just in some sort of melange of nothingness, but like, all of the arguments or the sort
of impressionistic stuff in this series of lectures is like, I see that Foucault, I see
that a little bit in Hegel, I for sure see it in Nietzsche.
And it's funny, because Heidegger basically says that throughout the series of lectures as
well.
It's like, this is the one question of all of philosophy, and for me and for everybody, this
is the only question is, what does it mean to think?
What does it mean to be a human being?
But on the flip side, just real quick, I did find this first lecture a little bit circular,
and it took me a while to kind of dig into it.
You know, the style, I mean, we've critiqued his style here and there, but I found it like,
okay, you're saying the same thing.
And I get that, you know, it's all auto referential.
And that's part of the thesis, basically.
But I'm like, can you try to say something else besides repeating yourself?
Like, just add, I don't know, just an example, anything.
Like, I felt, the second one for today, I kind of dug into, I was able to get some stuff
out.
But the first one, it just kind of felt like it plotted, plotted along.
Well, I liked it because it gave me a completely different sense of the way that he's thinking
of calling here.
And so, like, a lot of the sort of everyday usages of, like, what calls us to think, you
know, like, I had a sense of, like, okay, this is going to meet, there's going to be
the invitation, you know, what calls us to think, is calling us to become involved with
it.
But he had a lot of that, those kind of, like, common sort of articulations of his questions
where I just wasn't, I was hearing calling sort of, like, very telegraphically and not,
you know, in his relationship to a naming.
And I kind of liked what he did with the relationship between, say, calling something a name and what
calls to us.
And especially, like, when he started talking about the sense of command, right?
So, like, not a command as giving an order that is an imperative placed upon you, but
more like an invitation or an entrustment.
You have been entrusted with a particular requirement to care for a particular kind of thing.
So, you know, it definitely helped me reorient myself to the way that he's using the call
here.
You know, so we're starting with, this is, you know, we're on part two of the two-part
lecture series.
And we're just doing lecture one and lecture two.
And, you know, lecture one is he's sort of, like, restarting up the question, what is called
thinking?
Like, all right, there are four, this breaks itself up into four, you know, primary questions.
What do we mean by, you know, this question or this, what thinking, what does it signify,
this word thinking?
What is sort of, like, commonly said or what's the traditional doctrine of what we usually mean
when we talk about what thinking is?
What are the sort of prerequisites that are required in order to take up the activity of
thinking?
And then what is calling us or what is the call itself to take up thinking?
And he's, like, speculating, although it seems like it's not actually speculating.
That fourth question is the privileged one insofar as it is bringing up the other three.
It's involving the other three.
Right.
That's sort of the organizing question.
And all the other questions in some way spawn from it, or they're all related, but it seems
like that is the sort of foundational.
Because it's involving that command or compulsion or that push, that drive towards being and
thinking, right?
It's like all the other ones are at least a little bit superficial in regard to that primary
question.
But it definitely, I mean, the way that he takes on call there, which, you know, he's really
careful with how he uses the word command, and he doesn't, I think, want to think of it
as a compulsion, that, you know, it is much more of an invitation or an entrustment.
And that is a, that gives a very different flavor or character to thinking that, as opposed
to, like, the what we've been, how we've been thinking of it, almost as, like, a coping
mechanism, sort of, like, in that Zizek.
Right.
Well, the compulsion would be the common thinking.
I think that's kind of how he treats that here, where it's like, we tend towards representational
thinking, because it's more convenient, because it eases communication, engagement, it just
fits into modern techno-social society better, representational thinking.
Right.
So you slide into that as a compulsion, almost.
And he wants to get away from that with the more essential type of thinking.
Which, to me, like, and this has been an objection of John's, I think, throughout this.
I'm sitting, I'm sitting quietly here, just kind of waiting.
I know, because the opposition, I mean, we don't have to totally get into the weeds right
up front.
But, like, the opposition between common, commonness and Heideggerian-ness is, like, why, why is
there that opposition?
Like, it doesn't, I understand that representational thinking is a problem.
That, articulating it as a problem is fine, but treating it as unnatural and as improper seems
like just kind of a strange argument, if that's the way that everybody thinks.
If that's the way that everybody does things, how can you call that unnatural?
Just by virtue of the numbers, you know?
Yeah, I mean, it's interesting, because I had read this before when we were continuing, and
I remember at the time reading it and being like, okay, there's the annoying return to the
metaphorics of what I would just loosely call the metaphorics of authenticity or propriety
or whatever.
But it didn't bug me, because I was interested in the train going from the Nietzschean lineage
not, but now we took two months off, and I read it again last night, and I'm just like,
Jesus fucking Christ, like, honestly, like, I couldn't get through it without crossing out
and also just the relentlessness of his desire to say, you know, it's a story of alienation
that Heidegger perpetually tells, you know, which is, once we were authentically in language
in relation to being, and now we're not, and we've fallen out of, and so his desire is
to return to the proper domain of language and all these things.
And this is partly in response to the Daniel Gross stuff I read this weekend, but, like,
to me, that commitment, the fascism is right there, right?
Like, the notion that there is a proper relation that most people, you know, have fallen away
from that he wants to try to return us to.
Like, how is that not the basis of purity, propriety, all of the sort of deep metaphoric, and I
understand that there are ways of complicating the notion of essence in these things, but
everything about it seems to shout, like, we've fallen away.
Like, it's a Garden of Eden story.
Right.
Pre-lapsed area.
Once upon a time.
Right.
Exactly.
And in this case, it's not that we were in the state of pure presence.
We were in the state of pure non-presence, right?
Like, and we've fallen into the state of presence and representation.
Right.
Yeah.
And we have to try to get back to, which, I mean, Nate, I can't agree with you more.
Like, it's so unnecessary in terms of the thinking.
You could just say, these are different ways of thinking.
Right.
And this one affords something that this one doesn't afford.
So you can still make the distinction.
And again, if he did that, then I would want to say, well, does the distinction really hold
up?
You know, you'd want to do those kinds of moves of, like, or is it a temporary provisional
distinction where you want to say, oh, in fact, representation does something more than
represent, right, would be the next move.
But he doesn't even go, you know, it doesn't even go to that.
It really is a sort of, I mean, the language of, have to make an effort to live properly
with language.
Language properly inhabited.
What language really says, even though rare signification is the real one, right?
Like, the recurrence, and that's on one page, right?
The recurrence of this terminology of, like, this is the right, authentic, true, proper,
primary way of relating to language.
And it's like, that's a commitment.
It seems to be just strange.
Go ahead, Nathaniel.
I'll pick that up.
I was just going to say, there are a couple of passages that I think kind of, like, you
mentioned cross things out.
It's theological.
By the way, it's just, it's like, I can't read this without thinking of God.
Like, I can't read it without that.
Yeah.
No, I agree.
Like, the very first line of lecture two, what is most thought-provoking gives food for
thought in the original sense that it gives us over delivers us to thought.
I just crossed out original.
And I was like, now, like, in this sense, right?
But, like, he's got a couple of lines here that I think complicate it just a little bit.
I don't think enough, but just a little bit.
Like, on the bottom of 127, where he has been talking about sort of, like, the commonness
of the common, which I just love.
Like, he's just, like, people are floundering in the commonness of the common.
Such a, I know, I know.
Such a disdain for the common.
Yeah.
For every human.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, yeah, and I, but interestingly and relevantly, the disdain comes from the fact that they
think that they're individual isolated entities, that they aren't mitzah, they aren't being
in the world in common, right?
Like, that's the, so the problem with the common man is that they're not common, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Well, I mean, but to speak to the fascism kind of built in here, you know, this is the
third paragraph on 126, lecture two, where, you know, he's basically giving an account
of the draw, or, like, I would say, like, the performative force of the common, like, the
infinitive verb, to common.
Like, that paragraph reads, whether we are in any given case capable of thinking, that
is, whether we accomplish it in this fitting manner, depends on whether we are inclined
to think, whether that, whether that is, we will let ourselves become involved with the
nature of thinking.
It could be that we are inclined too slightly and too rarely to let ourselves become so involved,
and that is not so because we are all too indolent or occupied with other matters and disinclined
to think, but because the involvement with thought is itself a rare thing, reserved for few people.
And he so frequently talks about thinking as the essence of human nature.
So, if you have this rare, if the essence of human nature is rare at the sort of level
of, like, who has access to it and who doesn't, then you have to, like, that by definition leads
to the claim that most people aren't humans.
Most humans aren't humans, right?
Yeah.
I mean, it's, yeah.
I just wonder, like, if some of the terminology were just slightly shifted, if the message would
be less fascistic or just less...
Oh, I think it, like, requires, like, a two-degree shift.
Right.
And, like, get rid of all the proper propriety.
Yeah.
Get rid of all that language and just talk about differential relations.
Relationality.
Yeah.
You could do that, right?
I mean...
You could totally do that here.
You could just make those...
I don't think you'd have to add a word.
You would just have to...
You'd have to just remove a bunch of adjectives and adverbs.
Right.
And you did that, and you've got something really interesting.
But that's...
I mean, think of the difference for me with Nietzsche and interpretation and the genealogy
of morals when he describes interpretation, which is just, like, what is interpretation?
It's just picking something up here and putting it somewhere else, right?
That that's what it is.
And there's no question of an originary or an authentic or a prior...
Like, he makes fun of that.
He's like, no, that whole question makes no sense.
The originary would just be another placement, right?
Like, so there is no first placement, and the first placement has no priority, whereas
it so clearly does for Heidegger, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Or what he claims to be, and he finds it in the Greeks with his sort of etymological...
And I'm all down with the etymological jujitsu, except for that it's an attempt to capture
an originary sense.
Like, it just doesn't...
You just don't need to do that.
But at least...
I mean, for me, it's relevant that he does do that, and it is relevant to what makes Heidegger
Heidegger.
Exactly.
You know, and I find myself...
I'm so interested in...
For instance, he's one of the...
I keep returning to this, because you guys know my style disposition stuff.
Like, it's all over this, the how one inhabits the question, or how one hears, you know,
the call, or whatever.
It's like, I love all of that stuff, except for that he wants to say there's an original
right, proper way, and then everything else is a secondary sort of derivative manifestation
thereof.
And you're like, that is the whole metaphysics of the sort of appearance-reality dynamic
that you're supposedly problematizing.
But I don't, you know, that's the Lutheran sensibility, or I mean, whatever, the particular...
It's just...
Yeah.
It's the only thing that saves it or makes it more interesting than any of the, you know,
pre-Enlightenment or even Enlightenment, like pre-Descartes and including Descartes,
is that this is still an ontology of difference.
So, when he talks about the ambiguity of the question not just being a result of linguistic
ambiguity, but that it's an ontological ambiguity.
That's right.
The structure of relations is ambiguous.
Sentences like that kind of pull me out of the more vulgar sentences in these lectures,
but you're right.
I don't know if he just vacillates between fascism and difference, or if they are, you know...
No, I think that there's a fascism of difference.
Right.
Like, I mean, no, but I think that that's the point, right?
Like, for me, that's the point.
In other words, the kind of...
And I totally agree with you, because that's what I said before.
He has a beef here with the common way of doing things, but the common way of doing things
is that it doesn't take its commonality seriously enough.
It doesn't think of its commonality as fundamentally constitutive.
So, that second part, you'd be like, oh, here's a pluralist politics.
Like, here's a way, you know, that sounds great.
Except for the whole, in my terminology, the style that gets him to that kind of claim
is one that's organized around a scarcity, a rarity, an exception,
and specifically one that's thought in terms of purity and propriety.
Look at the bottom of 118, and this last paragraph on 118
is almost an articulation of, like, say, Derrida's differance,
or some kind of, like, linguistic drift,
except for, you know, the iteration, the citationality,
that kind of linguistic drift here
is, for Heidegger, a movement
away from something that is
more primary, rather than just
a movement that is away from
where it, you know,
from the last point, right?
But, I mean, that paragraph reads,
And, you know, that's obviously like His language speaks us, we don't speak language,
but here's the more pertinent lines.
For language plays with our speech.
It likes to let our speech drift away
into the more obvious meaning of words.
It is as though man had to make
an effort to live properly with language.
It is as though such a dwelling
were especially prone
to succumb to the danger of commonness.
And, you know, I mean,
I have a certain sympathy for that,
but I'll get to,
I'm going to save that for a little bit later.
I'm going to begin with the critique first,
is just that, you know,
there is, like,
there is a, that,
there's an essential ambiguity
at the heart of real language,
and that real language
constantly sort of inclines itself
to calcification, to reification.
It sounds very Nietzschean
in a certain kind of ways, you know,
like, what are words there,
there, there, you know,
these sense imprints
that have lost all of their sensory value
if they've just been worn away.
But, you know,
for the way that Heidegger's articulating it here
is that is almost always a problem.
He saves at one sort of, like,
false bit of praise, you know,
in the second lecture
where he says,
you know, such,
this is the bottom of 127,
such communication does not want
to lose time tearing
over the sense of individual words.
I thought of Hegel there.
Instead, words are constantly
thrown around on the cheap
and in the process
are worn out.
I thought of Nietzsche there.
There is a curious advantage in that.
With worn out language,
everybody can talk about everything.
Right.
So it's like,
there is a value to it.
It does allow us to be able to,
by the reduction of language,
allows for a certain kind of
pragmatism of language,
but it's not
a particularly valuable value.
The reductive capacity
is precisely what he's critiquing
and what Heidegger wants
to get away from.
And this is the not-
It's not thinking.
Right.
This is the not-so-subtle
but kind of subtle difference
between Heidegger's position
and if you want to couple him
with Nietzsche and Foucault,
whoever,
And that crew
And Hegel,
because Hegel provides
no alternative
to reduction
or appropriation.
Right.
So if you want to think
about the last man
as the guy
or the woman
or whoever
who is invested in
or enthralled
to representational
thinking being,
for Hegel,
that's all there is.
And for Heidegger,
there is,
you know,
we talked about the overman
in the previous chapters
and that,
there is something else
and that's what he's after
this whole time
is the other thing
that's not represented.
I mean,
think about the,
but think about that difference
right there.
Like,
for Nietzsche,
it's the overman
which is the speculative
future point.
For Heidegger,
it's the Greeks
which is the speculative
historical point.
Right,
like,
it's backwards,
not forwards.
And I mean,
to me,
that makes a huge difference,
right?
Like,
we've lost some
original primordial
versus we could achieve
some other kind of something.
No,
that is a key.
I mean,
Heidegger,
the fetishizing
of the Greeks,
I just don't understand.
I mean,
like,
I get that,
a lot of people do it.
Like,
a lot of people look back
towards the Greeks
as fulfilling some sort of
essence.
I mean,
Nietzsche,
right?
Like,
they all kind of,
even Hegel does it.
I mean,
you know,
he sees Aristotle
as like the guy
and like,
he sees his work
as an extension
of Aristotle's work
which it's just not.
I mean,
it's just a complete break
in certain ways
that he doesn't even recognize.
That's such an arrogant thing
to say about,
like,
Hegel doesn't even realize
the brilliance of it.
Whatever.
But,
but yeah,
you're right.
I just think it's a useful.
But Niccolo,
you'll get your philosophy.
That's me.
MVP,
baby.
But yeah,
like,
like what,
the paragraph
you just brought up,
Nathaniel,
I like highlighted a bunch
because I think like
to critique commonness,
representation,
whatever you want to call it,
is fine and good
and pretty much
every philosopher
post-Descartes
does some variation of that.
But why don't you
take it seriously?
If that's the guiding
mode of thinking
from then until now,
like,
why not like,
live in that a little bit
or at least
allow for its
endurance,
right?
As opposed to
offering some sort
of prescriptive policy
in Heidegger's case
of like stripping it
and getting back
to the bare essence
of human being.
This is,
yeah.
But like,
I wouldn't say,
I mean,
my approach
would not be that
because I feel like
There is,
there's an advantage
or there,
it's a tactical,
again,
stylistic.
It's just
comportment question,
but like,
I see an advantage
in saying,
so I had this moment
in my undergrad class
this semester
where something
sort of clicked for me
and I was trying
to understand
why every single time
I've ever taught
anything like
social construction,
just the basic logic
of social construction,
gender is socially constructed,
doesn't matter what,
people automatically
go,
oh yeah,
then it's free for all.
It has no truth,
there is no meaning,
right?
That's the default move
is there's nothing,
you know,
then there's nothing.
If it's socially constructed,
then it's not real
or something like that
and I'm just trying
to get my head around
why is that the default?
Like,
why is that the move
that just about every human
that I've ever taught
that idea to
automatically goes to
is that you're saying
that it's not real
and one of the things
I realized
and I talked about this
with my undergrad class,
they didn't get any
of this shit,
but I was like,
I think something
important here,
when I use the term
life,
let's say,
just,
you can pick anywhere,
pick death,
it doesn't matter,
like a term,
when I use the term death,
you guys think
that I'm referring
to something in the world.
I think
that I'm referring
to a concept
that attempts
to group together
a disparate series
of things in the world.
So when I talk
about death,
I am fully cognizant
that I am talking
about a concept
that attempts
to intersect
with the world.
They think
they are directly
talking about
the world that way.
So any claim
that I would make
about death,
and so therefore,
when you undo it,
they think it goes away,
whereas for me,
if you undo it,
you just need
Another concept,
like, you know,
nothing has gone away
just because you undo
the concept of death,
right?
Like, so in other words,
the extent to which
I so fully buy
a kind of Nietzschean
logic of,
conceptual construction,
right,
it's impossible
for me to really,
or it's possible
for me to have
an intervention
in that
that's not external
in a sense,
right?
Like, I'm always
going to be
a kind of loggerheads
because they're just
at a kind of
different,
their relation
between the concept
and the world
for them
is intuitively
and fundamentally
something that is
intuitively fundamentally
different than mine,
right?
Like, now my intuitive
and fundamental thing
has been learned,
right?
Like, I'm not saying
I was six
and I had this,
right?
Like, so, of course,
this intuitive
and fundamental thing
is trainable.
It's changeable
in that regard.
So, so, so to me
I go like, okay,
my project can't be
then to inhabit
that mode of thinking
because I can't.
I just can't.
I can't.
It's not possible
for me to think
of death
as referring
simply to events
in the world.
Right.
And, and so I have
to come at it
from, again,
a position that's
kind of external
to that epistemology,
that sort of epistemology.
Like, I just have to.
Yeah.
So the question
then becomes
what are the different
ways of doing that?
And what I, like,
what I just articulated
there is a self-conscious way.
It would be a very Hegelian.
Like, I've become aware
of the conceptual difference
between concepts
for me and for that.
Diagnostic, sort of.
That's right.
Right.
So it's, but it's still,
I mean, you're quite right
in this, say, like,
here's a difference, right?
Here's a difference.
And, and it's a difference
that I think
is really important
And it, a lot
follows from that.
If you start thinking
of concepts
as being ways
in which humans
organize a disparate
series of actions
as opposed to
representations of the world,
they're not,
I mean,
because ways in which
humans organize actions,
you know,
can itself be
representations of the world.
It's just,
you're taking
an epistemological step,
which I would say
is an ontological one
via Heidegger,
but it doesn't matter.
You know,
but it is a step
that's different
than the step
that they're on
and so therefore
teaching them
the logic of construction
at the point
that they are
is going to send them
somewhere different
that's not here.
Yeah.
Right?
I mean,
and that's that sense
in which, like,
ah,
there is a process here
and there,
it's a process
and I don't think
it's an intrinsic one,
but if you're
at this relation
and you're taught
this idea,
that will go here,
not here.
Yeah.
Right?
Like,
that's where,
this is going to be good
on a podcast,
the here and the here
and the,
the hand motion.
Yeah.
But you know what I'm saying?
It didn't go to a date together.
Yeah.
No, I definitely do.
Which is to say,
like,
you don't.
There's a process.
Yeah.
To say that there are
inclinations
and orientations
isn't to say
that they are natural
or embedded
or, like,
necessary,
especially necessary,
right?
No, certainly not necessary.
But, like,
given one
style
or kind of construction,
you know,
introducing a new element to it
is going to shoot it off
in one direction
rather than the other direction.
Right?
And that's...
And it always,
I mean,
you guys,
I'm sure,
Have had that experience.
You teach the logic
of construction
and the default thought
for literally
every single student
is,
oh,
that means it's not real.
Yeah,
that's exactly what I run into.
That's what makes it real,
right?
Like,
that's what makes it real.
But my approach
is to be,
is to say,
like,
we are in a building
that has been constructed
and by God,
I hope it's real
because otherwise
we're all going to collapse
here pretty soon.
And,
you know,
like,
because part of the fear
of the,
it's all constructed
is that it can be,
it can be changed
arbitrarily,
willy-nilly,
like,
it can be completely,
it can be,
because it's not real.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's not real
so it can become
something radically
different tomorrow.
I'm like,
well,
we can change this building
but it requires time
and labor
and material
and,
you know,
you're constrained
by certain,
you know,
whatever else
and,
you know,
and we're,
this building
is 70 years old
but the concepts
that we're talking about
are thousands of years old
and have mutated
over that time
but,
you know,
but it,
again,
it requires,
you know,
a kind of labor
and it is real
because it's constructed
and guess what?
Trees constructed
themselves too
and,
well,
and it,
so you say something like,
and I did,
I said this,
I said,
death is a concept
and they're like,
whoa,
and I'm like,
that's not a heady thing,
like,
I'm not,
I'm not saying anything
really big
when I say it
or at least
I don't think that I am.
It's just a way
of grouping together.
Like,
you look at that,
that tree outside
that's turning brown
and doesn't have leaves
and you look at,
like,
you know,
an old person
or something
and you say,
hey,
what's happening
to these things
is similar enough
that we're going to
call it the same thing,
right?
It's straight,
straight truth and lies,
right?
So that's a concept
called death
that I am homogenizing
what is clearly
an incredibly different thing
for that tree
than it is for that person,
right?
Like,
it's incredibly different
but we're going to
treat it homogenously.
I mean,
I think the issue
and this is what
Heidegger points to
is that most people
just don't want to do
what we see
as just a little bit
more work,
you know?
Because you say
the construction
of gender,
of death or whatever
Is a construction
but that it has import,
it has purchase
in the world
and so that doesn't
make it any less real
than an empirical phenomenon.
it's just that,
you know,
you have to kind of do,
people want an easy way out.
So like,
if you say constructions
make everything meaningless,
then it's just nihilism
and then you can,
you can just kind of
buy your way out that way.
You can reject it.
Or you can say
that death is only
strictly an empirical
phenomenon
that's measurable
and you know,
the biological body
expires,
whatever it is,
and you can identify
it that way,
capture it
and solidify it
in your head.
And so it's like
people,
there's a slowness
and you have to be invested
in your own thinking
to even get to
what we see
as kind of a basic
conceptual intervention
in constructionism.
I agree.
Well, yeah,
I mean,
I completely agree
in that,
you know,
we like to think
like the intervention
that people who think
like us tend to make
is to resist
that sort of
representational orientation
of language
and say no,
like language
is one force
among others
that is sort of,
you know,
working on and with
the world
and it's not sort of
transcendent
and representing it.
But that,
like language as medium,
language as conceptual medium,
accounting for the world
is,
you have to pass through that
before you can complicate it
and, you know,
I look at the way that like
Lachlan engages language
and, you know,
like a lot of our students
are engaged.
Like they are also engaged
in an immediacy of language
that there's not even
a representational function
for language.
Like death,
the word death,
the concept death
is also just death.
Like the empirical,
you know,
collection of phenomenon
that we've labeled,
like the work of the,
the work of the concept
of death
is so thoroughly constructing
in, you know,
the life world
of, you know,
like the immature
linguistic user
is that
it completely hides
its seams.
Is that,
you know,
the difference between
language in the world,
it is imminent,
just not imminent
in the way that
we have sort of
reasoned ourself
to see it.
Like they have to...
I don't know.
I mean,
I actually,
I actually kind of feel
the opposite.
Yeah.
Like,
yeah,
like I,
I mean,
and I,
I can't be wrong
about this,
so this is not a,
I'm not going to be
dogmatic about it,
but like I kind of feel
like it's,
you know,
I'll give you an example.
When I,
a long,
long time ago
when Aubrey was
a year and a half old
and this is when
I'm dating Sharon,
this is back in grad school
and I'm dating Sharon
and Aubrey's a year
and a half old
and I'm babysitting
with her and a friend
One day
and she and her,
like I'm reading out
in the living room
and she and her friend,
you know,
another two-year-old
or whatever
are playing in the back room
and,
you know,
I'm just sitting there
reading and suddenly
there's all this screaming
and I'm like,
and I jump up
and I run back there.
I'm terrified,
right?
And they're just,
they're just both
looking up at me
and I'm like,
what the hell's going on?
And they're like,
oh,
well,
we were playing
a screaming game.
I'm like,
oh,
fuck.
Okay,
okay,
do me a favor.
No more screaming game,
okay?
And they're like,
so I go out
and I sit down
and two minutes later,
ah,
all the screaming,
all the screaming
and I run back there
and they're like,
what's going on,
you guys?
And they're like,
what?
And I was like,
why were you screaming?
They're like,
no,
we were playing
a shouting game.
Wow.
And it was this moment,
they're two years old,
I'm not exaggerating,
right?
Like,
they're two years old
and they're like,
and they were just
dumbfounded
that I would have
mixed up
screaming and shouting
because they sounded
awfully frickin' similar.
And to me,
I'm like,
well,
who's the one
who's smoothing
over differences?
Yeah.
Right?
It's me,
right?
Like,
for practical purposes
and for totally
understandable ones,
but I am not making
a distinction
between screaming
and shouting
for the purposes
of them
and my concern
for their well-being,
right?
But they did
and they had no problem
making that distinction.
So,
and I also,
I mean,
To me,
and this is just
sort of phenomenologically,
experientially,
I always find,
like,
the concepts
with which I'm
understanding things
to make no sense,
to be so,
like,
just in my routine
everyday interaction.
And I'm saying
when I was 15 years old,
that was just as true
as it is
when I'm 50 years old.
Like,
these concepts of,
you know,
institution,
person,
scholar,
all these,
I'm like,
these just don't make
any sense to me.
They seem so coarse
and homogenizing.
So that's where I say,
like,
I'm not sure
that it's easier
and I'm not sure
that it's our natural inclination.
In fact,
maybe quite the opposite,
right?
That there's a kind of
training into
ignorance of difference.
Oh,
I think there's a training
in the ignorance
of difference,
but like,
you know,
I hear that story
And I hear that,
you know,
yelling and screaming
are two different ways
of categorizing
two different phenomena
in the world.
That yelling
is this,
not represents this,
and shouting,
screaming,
is this,
right?
And like,
I mean,
it's a profound literalness.
That's fair.
I mean,
what I find with Lachlan
is that he's at the stage now
where he has to develop,
in order to account
for what is basically
chaos in his life,
he has to account
for rules.
Even if those,
like,
he has to develop,
find rules
that explain
why this is like this
and why this is like this.
And he,
like,
has a certain kind
of will
toward figuring out
some kind of system
that can explain
why does this thing change
but this one over here
doesn't.
And,
you know,
he,
like,
learns language of,
you know,
when it's like this,
it's like this.
Or sometimes it's like this
and other times
it's like that.
And he just has to find
these little,
like,
he has to find for him
whatever the little,
sort of,
the machinic hinges are
that...
The if-then statements.
Yeah,
right?
like,
whatever kind of this...
And they're like,
they're absurd
if-then statements.
But at least it gives him
traction into the thing.
And he's totally fine
replacing them later on.
But he just needs
to be provided
with a pathway
of how to get from
this little machine,
explanatory machinery
to that explanatory machinery.
And that's exactly where,
I mean,
you know,
we are just,
I mean,
I find myself frequently,
it's just the truth
and lies,
I say,
right?
What concepts give you,
concepts of race difference
and they give you
a sense of order
And regularity.
And there are different ways
of living
in the realm of concepts
and one is believing
in them
and the other is
playing with them
or using them
provisionally,
we would say,
right?
Although I would say
kind of counter Nietzsche there
is that,
you know,
they can be
simply mobilized pragmatically.
Like,
don't play the screaming game.
By the way,
I also mean the yelling game,
the shouting game.
It covers everything.
It covers everything that is,
yeah.
But what I,
but like Lachlan's line
of questioning,
like his insatiable curiosity
is like,
all right,
you just gave me
a concept
or a category.
Now,
that has some implications to it.
So let's follow through
with those implications
and what does it mean
for these other things?
Because I thought
I had a handle
on these other things
but I clearly don't now
because you've messed
with that system
and then that one's
going to lead
to the next one
and it's the infinite
and it's not even just like,
you know,
he's not two years old anymore
where it's just Y, Y, Y, Y, Y, Y.
It's like,
okay,
given X,
then what does that have to do
with Y over here?
And then you just realize
that like following
that conceptual rabbit hole,
you know,
like,
you're just talking about
who's smoothing over differences?
It's like,
this game needs to stop
because we need to be able
to have dinner
or I am just not explaining,
you know,
this concept to you
which I know if I,
if, you know,
as soon as you can get this concept,
you're going to push it
to the next one
and it's ad infinitum.
I mean,
it's fun as shit
until it's not.
Well,
does he find,
does he seem to enjoy
like the process?
Like,
is he invested in an answer
or like,
does he want to just keep questioning?
Like,
does he just like the line?
He wants to keep questioning.
Like the thing,
like the most recent example,
so my mom is visiting
for the first time in two years,
which has been great
because the pandemic
has kept this,
you know,
we went to the park
and down at the,
at the harbor front,
there's like this big play structure
that's like shaped
like a submarine
and he basically like
interrogated my mom
about every last piece
of the submarine
and the main driving questioning
was sort of like,
all right,
what is,
what about this structure,
like this play structure submarine,
it resembles a real submarine
and what makes it
its play structure-ness
and how would that be different
from a real submarine
and,
you know,
trying to figure out
the logics of
why this one
is done this way
for the sake of play
and the other one
is done for the sake
of something else
and by the way,
do real submarines
have wheels on them
in case they get stuck
in the mud
and like,
if he was invested
in an answer,
I feel like
we would have hit upon one
that would satisfy him
but he's never been
satisfied yet.
There is,
every single case
been like
an arbitrary reason
To,
either he's been
just sort of directed
into another line
of reasoning
that culminates
in food or sleep
or,
or it's been,
you know,
cut off by,
whoever the adult is.
I feel like
that's exactly
how I live.
Like,
you just described
my life.
Yeah.
Like,
I'm just trying
to figure out
why these things
are connected
and why,
like,
what sense
it possibly makes
until I get
to food or sleep.
I actually think
like lots of kids
are curious
and questioning
and in fact
what education does
is stop that,
right?
it stifles it
or it channels it
in such a way
as to make the kids
not want to ask
questions,
you know?
The whole structure
of education,
even in primary school,
probably starting
in kindergarten,
it starts to stifle
that.
I mean,
and this is,
by the way,
this is exactly
what Heidegger
would say.
Yeah.
I just repeated
a mantra of it
like education
is what reduces us
into the realm
of representation
in technological thinking.
Yeah.
I,
and it's hard
not to agree
with that
for a certain,
from a,
to a certain degree
except that,
you know,
I think as we just
demonstrated,
you know,
I brought up like,
yes,
I'm biased.
I think Lachlan
is freaking awesome
but I also just think
that it's the internal
structure of the
categorical impulse
as well.
I just think about
the Socratic
like dialectic
is,
you know,
just think about
how many
Platonists
arbitrarily stop
the dialectical process
at a certain point
when they found
the answer
that they like
and then ignore
the X number
of pages afterwards
where,
you know,
the thing got turned
upside down.
Like in the
Gorgias,
for example,
like,
you know,
the rhetoric
as flattery
analogy.
I'm like,
all right,
well,
we found Socrates'
answer
and you don't realize
that's only halfway
through the dialogue
and shit changes.
not even that
and a lot of shit
happens between one
and the other
and the machinery
just never ends
and that sort of
like that impulse,
that categorical impulse,
which is always a
differential impulse,
right,
that, you know,
it's always producing
a difference,
like,
is insatiable
and it doesn't
have to be
used sort of like
purely for pragmatic
purposes.
and in fact,
if you follow it
strictly,
it never allows
itself to rest
long enough
to be used
satisfyingly
for pragmatic
purposes.
Now,
I do remember
like as a kid
kind of following
that line of
questioning
with my parents,
like,
I remember I would
do it to my dad
a lot,
like what you're
describing with Lachlan,
like I would just
incessantly
ask questions
and it was not
with the telos
of satisfying
with an answer,
right,
you're just kind of
playing with connections
and seeing where they go
and trying to be creative
and whatever,
but I do find that,
or at least I remember,
there were certain
questions that I did
want an answer
and I wanted one
desperately,
like we brought up
the question of death,
like as a,
as like a three
or four year old
or whatever,
for me,
like this was a,
you know,
it's a terrifying concept
for any child,
but like I remember
just being like
so confounded
that this would all end
at some point
and so I would just
like be telling my mom
like,
well,
what the,
what the fuck
do you mean?
And I said that exactly,
what the fuck
do you mean mom
at four years old?
What do you mean
we're gonna die?
Level with me.
And like the only way
she could soothe me
out of that
is by,
you know,
lying
and it,
it did.
I remember like
this exact conversation
she goes,
now by the time
you're older,
like science has progressed
to the point
where they will have
a pill,
that will allow you
to live forever
and that's the only way
she could get me
to shut the hell up
and like go to sleep
and be comforted
and I was like,
okay,
like by the time
I'm an adult,
we will never die.
well,
you know,
similar to that heaven story,
like I got the actual
heaven story,
you know,
when I would insistently
ask about that
as a kid
and that one scared me
more than death
because it was like,
you know,
heaven is a happy place
where we all are sort of
like living in the radiance
of God
and I was like,
holy shit,
so heaven is where
you have to be in church
all the time?
I hate being at church.
That's the last place
I want to be.
Eternally.
Yeah,
eternally,
like,
yeah,
can I die?
Can we go back
to the death thing?
My parents,
we didn't have the whole
God structure
in my family
so we went,
she went science,
she went,
there will be a pill.
No heaven,
there may be a pill.
It raises a question for me
because one of the ways
of responding to this
in both of your guys' examples
is to emphasize
the provisional quality
of all thinking,
right?
Like,
that it's sort of,
but,
and that seems like,
you know,
I've got a chapter
that I'm working on right now
called provisional thinking
and I want to say,
like,
look,
all thinking is provisional,
depends on the nexus
in which you're engaged
in the sort of circumstances
and the extraction
of any chunk of that
from one place
and putting it somewhere else
is an act,
right?
It is that one is doing something
when one does that.
But it kind of,
it kind of begs the question
of what counts as provisional
and for how long,
right?
Like,
you know,
like,
how long is the length
of a provision,
right?
If provisional just means
for pragmatic purposes
and it hooks me right back
into the question of context,
you say,
well,
in this context,
I was dealing with this question.
It's like,
well,
where does that context end?
Does it end at the end
of the chapter?
of the book?
Does it end at the end
of your life,
right?
Like,
what is the point
at which provisionality
is no,
you know,
becomes,
becomes universal
or the flip side
would be
is universality
just a provisionality
that lasts longer
than other provisionalities?
I mean,
I would think
you would have to think
of the performativity
of provisionality itself
or,
you know,
pragmatics itself
like to provision,
to,
like,
make pragmatic,
which is,
you know,
I think if you wanted
to find,
you know,
I would say
with every single beat,
you know,
the provisionality ends,
which would mean
for every single letter,
every single period,
every single whatever it is,
like,
there is no,
there is no staccatoed,
Actual staccatoed moment
in the,
in the flux of,
you know,
of becoming,
but you can always
sort of scrape out
this or that chunk.
You can provisionally
distinguish the provisional.
So it's not that
it is provisional,
it can be provisioned,
right?
Which is,
which is just another beat.
Because it,
because to say
it is provisional
would have to say
that there is
an is there,
but to,
but,
so,
so what you're doing
is just shifting it
like it's always
performatively assigned.
Exactly.
So because it's like
even the assignment
of provisional status
is itself provisional.
Yeah.
So you,
you never get out of that,
you know,
it's,
it's provisionality
all the way down.
Well,
yeah,
or that,
the provisionality
is a particular style.
Performative induced provisional.
Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
For Heidegger here,
I mean,
it would seem like
you could make the argument
that he's saying
that provisionality
is universality
in the sense that
he wants to leave
the question,
What Is Called Thinking
open-ended
seemingly perpetually.
The way to reach
the essence
of thinking
is to leave
the question
of thinking open.
Now,
you have to interrogate it
in certain ways
and there's probably
more productive ways
than others,
but leaving it opening
without answering it,
that's part of the essence.
So that provisional,
I don't know
if you would call
that provisionality,
but that attentiveness
to the context
of the question
and how it's mobilized
and what it's doing
to you in that
particular moment
and historically,
that's all part
of the universal,
which is also,
I mean,
that's a Hegelian
sort of thing.
Well,
that's the contingency
Is the only universality,
right?
Yeah.
But it's almost like
he believes too much
in representational thinking
or in the very possibility
of the reification
of thinking
that if there is
the originary point
and then what you can
fall away from it,
it's like you've fallen
into a particular state
where I think
the whole conversation
that we've been having
is,
no,
that drift
is itself
its own performative line
and yes,
maybe,
you know,
the number of,
like in that kind
of Spinoza sense,
the number of relations
is kind of reduced,
there is a kind
of deadening to it,
but it's never ever stopped,
it's never ever,
you know,
truly reified.
That's why it's interesting
because I don't like
the response
that you have
of the provisional
is always performatively assigned
and I think the reason
for that is because
it's so human,
right?
It ends up being like,
okay,
It's just humans
that decide.
No,
no,
no.
It feels that way.
I'm not,
I think the tree
like provisionally
carves out
the water
and the light
and the whatever
else it is.
Like,
how about
make,
think of like
the act of provisioning
is the same
as the act
of appropriating,
right?
Provision,
to say something
is provisional
just means
that it is appropriatable
and,
you know,
to provision
is just to do
the act
of appropriating,
which doesn't mean
it has to be
conscious
or human
or,
you know,
reducible to like
biological life,
right?
Either.
So,
because I think,
for instance,
I mean,
Just to return it
to the general scope
that I'm thinking
through is,
I want to say,
like,
all of the thinking
here is provisional,
which is to say
it matters in the,
you know,
it's relevant in the
nexus in which
I'm engaged,
but this is what
the structure
of the book
should show
is that from nexus,
from location
to location
it's going to shift
and so,
like,
the bodies without organs
concept,
right?
Like,
it'll shift
from place to place
but,
but it's,
I mean,
again,
I just,
like,
what is the scope
of regular,
then what is the,
what is the similarity
that one is mapping
through that concept?
You know,
why would you even
call it the same?
You know,
why would you say
it's the same concept?
I hear provisionality
and just what you just said
operating at three
different levels
at once.
The first is to say
that the thinking,
what is being produced
is itself provisional,
which would be to say
that it is not fixed,
that it is caught up
in a citational flux
that is always mutable
and appropriatable,
okay?
That's the one sense,
which is to say
none of this is fixed
or reified.
The second speaks to
a style of engagement,
is that I am
treating this
as something
that is
in flux
and becoming
and that I
am not going
to
like make
provisional claims
that reify
a part of it
even momentarily,
that I,
my aim
is to produce
a line of thinking
rather than
a,
a trial of space.
Heidegger says
that kind of thing
all the time.
All the time,
for sure.
Path of thought.
Right.
But then there's
the third way
is to say that
it is available
for provision,
which is,
it can then be
carved out,
like think about,
you know,
say like your
stasis chapter,
like the act
of the carving out
of the thing,
which can be,
you know,
like there's no,
there's no context
of your chapter
that has some kind
of natural boundaries,
right?
The fact that
it's a chapter
is one provisional cut.
Another provisional cut
could be someone else
citing it.
Another provisional cut
can be,
you know,
you're referring back
to it in another
kind of way,
but only,
you know,
this part,
this time,
that time,
this part,
another time,
this time it's like,
you know,
six different parts
across three different
chapters,
whatever it is,
It's only in the act
of making it provisional.
So I see provisioning
operating at three
different lines.
Yeah,
I see those distinctions.
But as I follow
through with it,
I'm like,
I lose any sense
of the distinction
between provisional
and whatever
would not be provisional.
Like,
isn't then everything
in all three
of those senses?
Like,
it's just all,
whether I call it that
or not.
Well,
I would say,
no.
In that first sense,
yes,
everything is provisional.
Nothing could not be provisional.
The second sense
would be the difference.
Here's how I'm going
to treat it.
Exactly.
And one might
treat it differently.
One might treat it
like Mucklebauer's
final statement on style
in this sentence
or something like that.
And here's like
a good place
where,
you know,
treating something
not provisional.
That's what content is.
And content is
The provisional separation
of a style
for a moment,
right?
Like,
that's...
Here's an example
for that.
Here's a content
that I'm interested
in not being overly provisional.
A bridge over a,
you know,
over a river,
right?
I would like
that to be
as,
you know,
unprovisional
as possible,
recognizing
that it can't fully,
you know,
attain that.
But,
you know,
I would like
that bridge
to be not,
or,
you know,
not be becoming
in any sort of like...
Right.
To stay there
when I'm driving
across the road.
Exactly.
Right?
And then,
you know,
the last one
speaks much more
to the act
of appropriation.
So that would be
the act...
I mean,
like,
I would,
you know,
the third one
is the act
of carving out beings.
Beings are provisioned.
But that's,
it's interesting to me then,
yeah,
but I like that
because content
just becomes
a fold of style.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's all it is.
Like,
and there,
so there really is
a distinction
between style and content.
Right.
It's that content
is a derivative fold,
a provisional fold
of style.
Yeah,
that is functional
and it's provision,
like,
it's provisionally functional,
right?
You fold,
you stylistically fold
in this way
and you produce
this kind of content
that,
you know,
is valuable
for these kinds of things.
I like that.
I'm going to use that shit.
Provisionally.
Well,
provisionally,
yeah.
I'll,
I'll cite you.
There are three senses
in which Nathaniel's treat
means provisionally.
Which I was definitely
not influenced at all
by Heidegger's
four senses of.
Right.
I'm going to get it done.
One.
There should be
a fourth sense
that undergirds them all
that is the pure,
authentic,
proper way
of understanding
provision.
We don't need that one.
The essence.
And also,
interestingly,
like the etymology
of the word,
like I would think
it would have something
to do with vision,
but it doesn't,
right?
It's,
it is the sort of
supplying of material
for like,
if you're going on a trip,
you get provisions,
right?
Like,
it's not pro-vision.
It's not pro-vision,
no.
It's the,
I can't remember the Latin,
but it was,
I can't remember,
the Latin word
had nothing to do
with seeing,
you know?
Because I was like,
provision is going
to be perfect.
That's going to be
the word for theory,
right?
Like,
it's going to be
in favor of theory.
Yeah,
yeah.
And I was like,
that's going to,
this is going to be
the title,
like provisional thinking,
right?
Right.
But it doesn't work
that way.
Okay,
but now I've got a question
that I've wanted to ask
from the beginning
about etymology
and the value
and the function
of etymology
is that I think
all of us find
an incredible value
in it,
and I think that
we're all uncomfortable
with the value
that Heidegger places
on it,
that it's going to
lead you to
the originary thing.
And yet,
okay,
so,
you know,
I'm going to anticipate
boo to Heidegger,
like etymology
gets you to
the core essence
of the thing.
Hooray for that.
It's a way
of producing
senses
of
provisionally
creating senses
of things
or like
dislodging
reified
senses of something.
I love that
as an aside,
he's dismissing
the commonplace
theory
renderings
of responses
to the question
he has yet to pose.
I've been reading
a lot of Heidegger.
But in the between,
you know,
I mean,
I do think
that there is
a kind of
drift of language.
You know,
I think of all of,
like,
think about the word
idiot
and the way
that sort of like
its sense of
idiosyncratic.
I think about it a lot
on this one.
Sorry,
it was just sitting there
and I had to say it.
Okay,
the senses of like
idiot,
dumb,
you know,
whatever.
Like,
think of like,
they're all just sort of
Generically,
you know,
someone is not smart.
I'm like,
no,
like,
well,
idiosyncrasy
is different
than lacking,
you know,
a certain capacity
to articulate
language is different
from,
you know,
like us being
in a stupor,
right?
Or,
or mean is one
that I often,
you know,
work with my students
is that,
especially when we're
talking about,
you know,
those Cicero's cases,
like the mean audience.
I'm like,
no,
they're not,
you know,
petty and angry at you.
It's a sense of like,
you know,
in terms of ends
and means
and like,
you know,
the mean person
is only focusing
on the means
by which one
can attend to
the,
get to the end,
which means
they're not considered
Of,
you know,
someone's feelings
or something.
And,
you know,
so I do find like,
there is a kind of
almost deadening
of language
as it sort of
circulates within,
you know,
common discourse
and that there is
an energizing function
of etymology
and it does provide
a,
it does provide
food for thought
in a sort of like
in an enriching way.
And so like,
you know,
I don't want to suggest
that,
you know,
every etymology
is,
you know,
just as good
as another one,
that there is
a certain value
in tracing,
you know,
a word back
to what's almost
sort of like
most proto,
you know,
conceptual,
intersections.
But I don't want
to say that the value
of that is
caught up in its
authenticity or originality.
So like,
What's the value
of etymology for you?
But why not just,
I mean,
why can't you just say,
like anything
can be food for thought
in that,
to that extent.
It doesn't have
to be etymological.
It could be
walking down the street,
right?
Like,
so etymology to me
is just a hook.
It's one way in.
It gives you,
here are other ways
and other senses
of the word
that come from history.
You know,
and so to me,
I'm like,
oh,
that's interesting.
I don't think
that when I'm using
the word mean
now,
that I am then
participating
in that
antique version
in some indirect
or subtle way.
I am not.
I am participating
in the contemporary version,
you know,
but I can,
but as a cause
for thinking,
it's like,
oh,
here's an interesting
way in which mean
circulates.
It's polysemous,
right?
And so,
and I often,
I mean,
sometimes when I read
Heidegger's etymology,
like the call stuff
was less impressive
to me because I was like,
all he's saying
is there are four meanings
of the word call.
Yeah.
That's like any dictionary
will tell you that,
right?
Like you don't have
to get etymological
and you don't have
to get authentic.
You get to say
there are four meanings
of this word,
especially a word
like thinking
for fuck's sake,
right?
Like there are many,
I mean,
how about if,
I would find it
incredibly useful
if he just said
there's six meanings
of the word thinking,
you know?
Like,
so to me,
just saying there,
the sort of emphasizing
the polysemous quality
can introduce connections
for obvious reasons,
right?
Like,
so this,
you know,
the word mean
has multiple,
Now mean meanings,
we're going to get
all into that,
but like any given word
has multiple meanings
just because historically
they're performatively
produced.
That's to me
super simple
and some of them
can be interesting
and informative.
I don't see,
and I don't like
the polysemous response
to it because then
it tends to like silo
each one of those meanings
and,
you know,
there is a,
I just read
Signature Event Context
again recently
is like,
there is a particular
communication
across those meanings.
Like they,
like these senses
communicate with each other
and that,
you know,
that our,
our contemporary sense
of meaning
has a particular
relationship
to that more
archaic sense
of meaning
and that
one is a bit
of a mean jerk
to only focus
on the means,
you know,
from the ends
and,
but 90%
of the,
99%
of the time
when someone
calls another person
mean,
it has absolutely
nothing to do
with means
and ends.
See,
I disagree.
I think that there is,
like,
I think there is a sense
in which they're getting
at that,
not consciously,
not like,
or even like the word
I mean this
as opposed to
I mean that
still has a connection
to means
and ends
where the word
is the means
of getting to
the content
and there's like
that meaning
relationship.
Can you make,
I mean,
there's a difference here.
Can you make that connection?
Of course you can make
that connection.
Like,
that connection
can be made.
Is that the connection
that the person
is making
in any kind
of conscious
way at all?
No.
Like,
there's just not.
No, probably not.
The word has come
to signify
something different
and to be used
differently.
I don't think
that it,
when we say
it harbors a trace,
it depends on
what we mean by that.
Obviously,
like,
if it's the Derridean trace,
it's not present.
There isn't something there.
So,
and I agree,
like,
to that extent
it harbors a trace
if we say
a non-presence.
It doesn't harbor
a hidden signification
of its originary use.
Right.
Like,
it's,
it got,
I mean,
so again,
that's where
the Deridian
versus the conventional
understanding
makes a difference.
But,
you know,
that's the
Nietzschean interpretation.
You take the word
from one place
and you put it
into another place.
Did it come
from somewhere?
Absolutely.
Right?
Like,
and does that somewhere
make a difference?
Yes,
but not necessarily.
Like,
can one hook the thing
and reactivate it?
Yeah,
of course.
Or,
or not determinately.
that it doesn't necessarily
make a difference
and it makes
a particular difference
but it's not
a predetermined difference.
It's certainly
not predetermined
because,
I mean,
as you just said,
it's not a silo
so that sort of
original signification
wasn't just a
self-contained entity
of this.
Right.
I mean,
that's how we,
that's how we treat it.
It's like,
okay,
well,
it was means,
ends,
and now it's nastiness.
Yeah.
And we can reactivate
the means,
ends thing
into the nastiness.
It's like,
no,
It wasn't simply
a distinct means,
ends thing,
that there was a sensibility
for its use
that was around,
you know,
and so that's to me
the much more ambiguous way.
That's how language works,
right?
There's always,
to me,
honestly,
one of the targets
that's ended up being
a target in this style book
is connotation,
denotation.
Like,
that distinction.
Right.
Yeah.
Right?
Like,
I just think that it's,
like,
I'm trying to find
the history of it
and I can't get too much
in terms of the history of it.
Ironically,
I'm trying to get
the history of how
the distinction.
But I mean,
the idea that you can
separate out
the denotative meaning
from the connotative use
is,
I think,
disastrous
for thinking about language.
You know?
Yeah.
And yet,
I mean,
and yet,
you know,
the difference between
saying connections
can be made
and connections
have been made
matters,
right?
Like,
you know,
the more,
just like,
the more
that connection
between the two senses
of meaning,
that connection
was made,
right?
Of course,
yes.
And the repetition
of that has allowed
for an easier passage
between,
and a more sort of,
like,
a messier passage
between the two,
where,
you know,
I do,
like,
when I explain
that connection
to my students,
they're not like,
whoa,
these are totally
different senses
of meaning.
Wow,
hasn't it?
Interesting how one word
becomes something
radically different.
Like,
oh no,
I totally see
that passageway,
and in fact,
I see in my everyday
usage of that word,
I see elements
or traces,
yeah,
like,
I see like,
instrumental,
an instrumental person
is a mean person,
right?
Exactly.
Yeah.
So the issue,
I guess,
that you might find
with Heidegger's
use of etymology
is that
whatever the original
structure of the word
and meaning of the word
that he digs up,
that somehow deserves
foundational status,
it seems like.
Like,
with his use of,
even the word to call,
which,
the notion that call
means an invitation,
that's not an unfamiliar,
I don't know why,
which he kind of
phrases it as such,
he's like,
this is the real meaning
of to call,
whereas the Deridian,
like you were just saying,
approach to etymology
is just to play
with a series
of interpretations
and mobilize them
for use
in another context.
I mean,
That's how the concept
difference came into being.
It's not that he gets
to the root of the word
and then somehow derives
an ultimate foundational meaning
of difference through it,
it's that he's,
he's forcing connections.
It's not that he gets to the root of the word.